What is that?
Uh...
It-- It's the speech Hop wrote
for you and Mike.
Speech?
Yeah. You know, the heart-to-heart.
He never talked to you, did he?
[scoffs]
Can I read?
[Hopper] "There's something I've been
wanting to talk to you both about.
I know this is a difficult conversation,
but I care about you both very much.
And I know that you care about each other
very much.
And that's why it's important that
we set these boundaries moving forward,
so we can build an environment...
where we all feel...
comfortable...
trusted...
and open...
to sharing our feelings."
Feelings.
[murmurs]
[Hopper] Feelings.
Jesus.
[chuckles]
The truth is,
for so long,
I'd forgotten what those even were.
I've been stuck in one place,
in a cave, you might say.
A deep, dark cave.
And then,
I left some Eggos out in the woods,
and you came into my life and...
for the first time in a long time,
I started to feel things again.
I started to feel happy.
But, lately, I guess I've been feeling...
distant from you.
Like you're...
you're pulling away from me or something.
I miss playing board games every night,
making triple-decker Eggo extravaganzas
at sunrise,
watching westerns together
before we doze off.
But I know you're getting older.
Growing.
Changing.
And I guess...
if I'm being really honest,
that's what scares me.
I don't want things to change.
So, I think maybe that's why
I came in here,
to try to maybe... stop that change.
To turn back the clock.
To make things go back
to how they were.
[Hopper sighs deeply]
But I know that's naive.
It's just...
not how life works.
It's moving.
Always moving, whether you like it or not.
And, yeah, sometimes it's painful.
Sometimes it's sad.
And sometimes...
it's surprising.
Happy.
So, you know what?
Keep on growing up, kid.
Don't let me stop you.
Make mistakes, learn from 'em,
and when life hurts you,
because it will,
remember the hurt.
The hurt is good.
It means you're out of that cave.
But, please,
if you don't mind,
for the sake of your poor old dad,
keep the door open three inches.
[laughs]
[sniffles]
[sobs]
["Heroes" by Peter Gabriel playing]
♪ I ♪
♪ I will be king... ♪
[knocking on door]
Are you okay?
Yeah.
[sniffles]
Time to go?
Yeah.
I'll be out in a minute.
Okay.
♪ Oh, we could be heroes ♪
♪ Just for one day ♪
♪ Oh, we can be us ♪